[Music]
September 2010 the GOI one satellite
captures photographs of the Chinese
capital Beijing one image shows a
cluster of apartment blocks next to a
lake but one of the towers doesn't look
right
it appears to be half skyscraper half
mountain we see this one skyscraper that
is covered with what appears to be an
enormous rockery I think that's pretty
awesome I mean that's one of the
craziest skyscrapers I've ever seen the
image is captured in the heidn district
of beijing eastern china the address of
this apartment block appears in several
reports to local authorities of strange
activities on the roof local residents
started complaining about noise about
weird objects being hoisted up to the
roof very long waits for the elevator
leaks and cracks are starting to form
all over was easy to tell the wind hila
possible higher national data finds it
that's a good question I don't
a local drone operator flies a camera
over the rooftop to get a better look at
what could be causing the problems
the drone spots an artificial mountain
on top of this building with shrubs a
swimming pool it's the size of two
basketball courts this is totally crazy
the aerial footage reveals the huge
mountain like structure is two storeys
high has its own Sun Terrace and even a
vineyard this is incredible to me that
this luxury mountain retreat went
unnoticed for so long I want to know how
he did it and like did he you know climb
up every day with a few rocks in his
pockets like I mean it's it's insane
like how do you do that in secret
without anybody knowing this was a huge
amount of work you see these massive
metal structures on the sides of the
towers to hold it all together this is
no roof garden officials give the owner
of the top floor penthouse two weeks to
remove his rooftop mountain
let's okay days later workers start to
remove the weird mountain its owner was
given just 15 days to dismantle what
took more than six years to build rumor
has it that one year on they're still
struggling to take it down